let's talk about Chess Luca okay so why
do you love chess right since I was a
kid you know growing up I was playing
chess I was like the I always call it
the mind game so that's what I love it
our basketball and chess similar uh for
me I always say you know you gotta rate
what the other person is going to do so
I think that's why the similarity about
that school and chest
what's it like playing chess against
Dirk I mean for me it's easy because I
beat him all the time but for him it's
kind of hard
what's your style of play
I'm more of a tech guy you know just
like basketball or not a lot of
difference but attacking is my option
why did you give Luke AI chest skills
because I really love chess and you know
there was opportunity to put like Luke
AI in the game so I was really excited
about that